Sudanese refugees in eastern Chad are on
the move again
cramped conditions in their camp and
tension within the host Community is
forcing the United Nations to relocate
thousands from the town of address
fled the first war in therefore but
returned home 10 years ago last month
the violence in was therefore forced her
back into Chad three days after she
delivered a baby through cesarean
section
she's one of the first batch of refugees
relocating to a new camp
I hope we get help at the new camp more
food Healthcare and shelter
with religious is running out of funds
it's hard to say if our expectations
will be met
we have less than a month's stocks so
basically those are the last last
distribution if we don't manage to bring
more immediately more stocks
the United Nations High Commissioner for
refugees says the new camp will address
the concerns of both the refugees and
host Community there are already houses
for at least 500 to 800 families there
are latrines there are water points
there are there is a clinic so the idea
is to bring these people to a place
where they can have a much better
quality life
conditions in that Ray are getting more
desperate food shelter and medicines are
about to run out the world food program
says it lacks the funding to continue
feeding tens of thousands of refugees
malnutrition cases are on the rise with
Aid agencies saying children are dying
due to lack of food
residents say relocating the displeased
will bring some relief to the
overburdened Border Town
[Music]
we have an alarming situation regarding
inflation in our tray because of the
large number of refugees here prices
have doubled and even tripled it's
specially affected is rice and other
food stuff worsening the social
situation
some 55 000 refugees remain in at Ray
they are in desperate need of food and
shelter
but with donor fatigue setting in
another crisis raging around the world
help could be a long way off
Ahmad Idris Al Jazeera a ray on the Chad
Sudan border